[Music]
you've described yourself as bluish yeah
all right in Jewish black and Jewish the
term is bluish yeah okay Oh tell us
what's involved when you're when you're
bluish Wow what's life like well you
know growing up my mom and my dad my dad
was Jewish my mom's african-american and
so they would celebrate everything in
all things from both cultures so we
would celebrate Easter and Passover we
would celebrate Hanukkah Kwanzaa and
Christmas you got all of those and I got
wow I just got a high-five I never get a
high-five
wow that's incredible what's what do you
get for Kwanzaa I'm ashamed to say I
don't even know wouldn't you what gifts
do you get on Kwanzaa you know it's more
so celebration it's more so celebrating
the heritage I'm not buying that it's
gotta be there's gotta be toys and
you're only in it for the gifts yes
pretty much yeah bring out the gifts
whenever I hear it's a spiritual affair
I go no we're gifts in the back now you
were on Full House the show full house
when you were five years old now here's
the crazy thing you still you have fans
that see the reruns and they recognize
you from the reruns and I don't let's
take a look at a picture of you from
here adorable
that is how that is how Andy dressed
when I met him at a line of clothing
yeah it myself
Oshkosh B'gosh phase what I don't
understand is so people see you see that
girl
and then they see you walking down the
street and they know that you're her you
were Denise on Full House and I'm like I
was five years old
please tell me I've changed somehow you
have changed yes are you wearing
overalls on a yeah
you